peck d'utilité été éditées chaque fois
mais je trouve à ma mère devient moments
creux de moi tu fait l'ena tout début
mais là tu étais la seule fille qui me
fait ça que tu commentes innocent iii
m'inquiète car tu me plais tout le
tralala du vuc tel fitch et des couettes
eu tout ça me met dans l'embarras
pourquoi moi je veux mais dans ce drôle
d'état pour toi pourquoi toi rechercher
ses pulsions l'année ne cède pas mon
truc
avant toi pourquoi toi tu me troubler ce
point là j'y crois pas pourquoi toi je
vais quand même pas te faire du plat va
falloir que je remets mon coeur à
l'endroit pourtant avant de te connais
tu jeûnes flash et que pour de boga pas
les plus machos peut-être mais enfin il
en avait lancé tu vois là soudain du
chanteur tour ne voulaient
de beaux draps rythme oui toi même et tu
as fait naître de drôle dans vie qui ne
s'avoue pas pourquoi moi je me mets dans
ce drôle d'état pour toi pourquoi toi
j'ai jamais
sur la lune elles ne cèdent pas mon truc
avant toi pourquoi toi tu me trouves le
ce point là j'y crois pas en quoi
pourquoi toi je vais quand même pas de
faire du club va falloir que je remets
mon coeur à l'endroit j'aimerais me
dévoiler m'avait dit mais tu y aurait le
chat gris tueur pas du vent c'est
malhonnête délire tat est neutre au
petit jeu fallait tremblay devient bête
je m'appuyais murata titue quand tu veux
profiter quand elle portait
exclusivement masculine authentique et
antiquités encore keaton qui quittent
indiqué tang encore des kits antiquités
qui tendent encore il indiqué tandis que
tango et quittant dire qu'il me montre
tout vigilante et qui portent voir
fondre entre meilleure densité j'aime
pas quand elle rencontre le titre james
r
jeanne
c'est tombé à genoux devant l'état
je serai 2
un retrait pleut
là pourquoi moi je me mets dans ce troll
d'état pour toi
pourquoi toi j'ai jamais
cette pas mon truc avant toi pourquoi
toi tu me trouves la ce point là j'y
crois pas pourquoi pourquoi toi je vais
te
va falloir que je remets mon coeur à
l'endroit chaque fois que je te vois pas
bêtes y invoque en creux de moi qui fais
ding ding équipe est tu es la seule
fille qui me fait ça comment dire sans
devoir inquiète tu me plais tout le
tralala vu que tu es une fille j'ai des
couettes
tout ça me met dans l'embarras pourquoi
moi je me mets dans ce drôle d'état pour
toi pourquoi toi j'ai jamais eu
c'était pas mon truc avant toi pourquoi
toi tu me trouveras ce point là j'y
crois pas pourquoi toi je vais quand
même pas à faire du plat va falloir que
je remette mon quart à l'endroit
comportement